garcelle red hot tonight what inspired
you've been rocking the red for a moment
I have but what inspired the change up I
was bored over the holidays and I was
sick and I thought what am I going to do
different this season and then I thought
red and here we are I didn't think I was
gonna like it and because I have to dye
my hair a lot because of Grace that I
was like I don't know but so far so good
has that set the tone for how you're
approaching this season is it a red hot
season you better believe it I am taking
no prisoners
peripherally involved in scandival
kids
I mean when you saw this all start to
play out you kind of knew you knew it
happened but it's blown up into this
whole other thing now well I
when it became bigger than what Oliver
did I was like
thank God it's not about just him
um yeah I mean listen Oliver's a grown
ass man do I agree with everything he
does absolutely not but I love them and
what are you gonna do did you watch the
episode or did you avoid the episode
were away we were in Vegas or days later
and I found myself washing it through my
fingers you don't want to see your kid
make out and it felt like it was like
the entire episode felt like it slowed
down to a crawl they literally slowed
down the footage
I couldn't take it did he call you up
like Mom how do I deal with a reality TV
Scandal how do I get out of this like I
don't think realities for me and I go
good it's not it's not gonna become the
family business no no we know you're
gonna pop up on Vanderpump Rules sooner
rather than later have you convinced lvp
to repay the favor and come and film
with you for this show you know it came
this close I almost got her to come to
my uh my movie screening that I had and
uh she chickened out
okay Lisa you never know I'm still
talking to her about it okay it's early
days still it's early it's I would love
it and I think some would love it and
some would not yeah how do do the women
give you the business about having a
friendship with her they don't but if I
bring her up I hear chatter I hear stuff
and I just ignore it I pretend I don't
hear it your girl Denise recently popped
up filming Camille's popped up filming
Cynthia Bailey's popped up filming no
Kim Richards on a hike I heard it's a
smorgasbord yeah the smorgasbord ghost
from Bravo's past right is that a good
thing or a bad thing do you think I
think it's a good thing I think all the
people who are coming back people love
so I think it just enhances our show I
mean they're not the entire season but I
think it's fun I think it's good and
we're there's some fresh blood in the
waters tonight Anne-Marie Wiley's just
around the corner have you gotten a
chance to connect with her meet her yet
no I haven't met her yet
tonight might be the night yes all right
so we don't have a read on her yet nope
is there I mean Kathy also seems to be a
question mark do you think she'll pop up
before the end of the season oh that
would be a big bet I don't know I think
you know it between Kyle and and her it
goes deeper so I don't I don't know I
would like that but I have no idea how
has the energy shifted with Lisa Arena
not in the room to stir the pot
oh she's not around
um I don't know I feel fine I think
we're really good
so a red hot season all good familiar
faces new faces we're checking a lot of
boxes here we are and congrats on the
launch of the production company oh
thank you so much I'm so excited what's
on the Slate what are you working on
next few things okay there's a few
things that Denise need to do a lifetime
movie together I know I know I actually
mentioned that to her the other night
okay yeah let's make it happen we'll
make it happen
I'll let you get in all right nice to
see you too
[Music]
foreign